In this segment, we discuss a
few algebraic properties of
the covariance.
There is nothing deep here, only
some observations that
can be useful if we want
to carry out covariance
calculations.
We start by looking at this
quantity, the covariance of a
random variable with itself.
So it's a special case of this
definition but where Y is the
same as X. And therefore, this
second term here is the same
as the first term.
And so what we're left with is
the expected value of the
square deviation of the random
variable from its mean.
And we recognize that this is
the same as the variance of X.
So we conclude that the
covariance of a random
variable with itself is the
same as the variance.
Now, for the variance, we had an
alternative formula, which
was often convenient in
simplifying variance
calculations.
Is there a similar formula for
the case of the covariance?
Let us start from the definition
and use linearity.
We have a product here of two
terms, and we expand that
product to obtain four
different terms.
The expected value of the sum
of these four terms is going
to be the sum of their
expectations.
So let us go through
the steps involved.
We have the expected value
of the product of this
term with that term.
Gives us expected value of X
times Y. Then we take the
expected value of the product
of this term with that term.
And because we have a minus
sign, we put it out here.
And we have the expected value
of X times the expected value
of Y inside the expectation.
The next term is going to be the
product of this expected
value with Y. And that gives us
minus the expected value of
X times Y. And finally, the last
term comes by multiplying
this quantity with
that quantity.
And this is what we have by
applying linearity to the
definition of the covariance.
Now, remember that the expected
value of a random
variable is a number,
it's a constant.
And constants can be pulled
outside expectations.
So if we do that, what we
obtain is the following.
We pull this constant outside
the expectation, and we're
left with the expected value of
X times the expected value
of Y. Similarly, for the next
term, by pulling a constant
outside the expectation, we
obtain this expression.
And finally, for the last term,
we have the expected
value of a constant, and
this is the same as
the constant itself.
We recognize here that
the same term gets
repeated three times.
And because here we have a minus
sign, we can cancel this
term with that term.
And what we're left with is just
the difference of these
two terms, and this is an
alternative form for the
covariance of two random
variables.
And this form is often easier
to work with to calculate
covariances compared with
the original definition.
Let us now continue with some
additional algebraic
properties.
Suppose that we know the
covariance of X with Y, and
we're interested in the
covariance of this linear
function of X with Y. What is
the covariance going to be?
To simplify the calculations,
let us just assume zero means.
Although, the final conclusion
will be the same as in the
case of non-zero means.
So in the case of zero means,
the covariance of two random
variables is just the same as
the expected value of the
product of the two
random variables.
And using linearity, this is the
expected value times a of
X times Y plus b times the
expected value of Y. Now, we
assumed zero means, so
this term goes away.
And what we're left with is a
times the covariance of X with
Y. So we see that multiplying
X by a increases the
covariance by a factor of a.
But adding a constant
has no effect.
The reason that it has no effect
is that if we take a
random variable and add the
constant to it, the same
constant gets added
to its mean.
And so this difference
is not affected.
As our final calculation, let us
look at the covariance of a
random variable with the sum of
two other random variables.
Again, we assume zero means.
And so the calculation
is as follows.
The covariance is the
product of the two
random variables involved.
And then we use linearity of
expectations to write this as
the expected value of X times Y
plus the expected value of X
times Z.
And we recognize that this is
the same as the covariance of
X with Y plus the covariance
of X with Z. So in this
respect, covariances
behave linearly.
They behave linearly with
respect to one of the
arguments involved.